[Musik]
genau ja
dieser Brieffreund wartet in den USA im
Bundesstaat Florida auf seine
Hinrichtung
[Musik]
mein Name ist mein Name ist William
copshow ich bin seit 21 Jahren im
Gefängnis ich wurde zum Tode verurteilt
weil ich jemandem das Leben genommen
habe
ein Verein namens lifespark vermittelt
seit fast 30 Jahren Brieffreundschaften
mit Menschen die in der Todeszelle
sitzen
in der längere mehr war ich Köder
[Musik]
ich habe erwartet Monster zu sehen zu
finden und ich habe Menschen
gefunden
[Musik]
in vielen Fällen entstehen tiefe
Freundschaften
im Wissen darum dass das Gegenüber
irgendwann hingerichtet wird
[Musik]
Medizinstudent Patrick Gerber lernt für
eine Prüfung
irgendwie immer mit dabei sein
Brieffreund William cop-show seit
einigen Jahren einer seiner engsten
Vertrauten Rotz rund 40 Jahren
Altersunterschied
geht's in Bezug ins Studium
damit ihr
intensive mit dem Stoffes lang setzen
und mir auch nichts festesituationen
Prüfungsstress im Studium beschäftigt
den einen die bevorstehende Exekution
den anderen
bei solchen Brieffreundschaften Rollen
Welten aufeinander
Situationen
und entsprechend Platz
ja das ist toll wenn Ihr Urlaub macht
oder mit Freunden essen geht
schickt er mir Fotos
das gibt mir das Gefühl dabei zu sein
und das ist wunderbar
durch ihn fühle ich mich zwischendurch
wie ein freier Mann
zumindest in meinem Geist
Patrick Gerber wollte sich sozial
engagieren und las zufällig einen
Artikel über Brieffreundschaften mit
Menschen in der Todeszelle also meldete
er sich beim Verein und bekam einen
Gefangenen zugeteilt dem schrieb er
zuerst Briefe heute E-Mails
würden Sie uns erzählen was sie getan
haben
lieber nicht
wer meinen Namen googelt findet viele
Informationen
aber das ist nicht die ganze Wahrheit
Patrick kennt die ganze Wahrheit
ja schreibt dass sie
sehr überraschend
[Musik]
das Gespräch aber er ist ganz klar
entsprechend verstorben
ich will dass alle wissen dass ich meine
Tat sehr bereue
und ich schäme mich auch für das was ich
getan habe
ich habe viel Menschen sehr weh getan
der Familie des Opfers und meiner
eigenen Familie
es tut mir unendlich leid
wenn ich noch mal zurück könnte würde
ich alles anders machen
Kathrin Studers Korrespondenz mit ihrem
Brieffreund Luther fühlt bereits mehrere
Ordner
sie sammelt alles was er ihr schickt
Briefe E-Mails und Karten
dass ich die Frau bin dort die
Freundschaft ermöglichen und auf freut
sich auf
die Freundschaft wo wir mit der
und das ist ja passiert jetzt ja das ist
passiert das ist jetzt wirklich für mich
richtig tief Freund
ihr Brieffreund schreibt wie es ist rund
um die Uhr in einer Zelle zu sitzen und
von seinen Höhepunkten zweimal Hofgang
pro Woche
und was genau geschrieben
sie betreut ihren Mann Daniel der an
einer Augenkrankheit leidet keine
einfache Aufgabe aber bekanntlich ist ja
alles relativ
[Musik]
Patrick Gerber will Arzt werden und die
Welt bereisen
im sei bewusst geworden was für ein
privilege sei Pläne haben zu dürfen und
frei zu sein
seit amerikanischer Pfarrer wo die
trackt Insassen betreut hat Markus
mit einem
machen
dass es im Todestrakt ist wenn man sich
überlegt und Relation setzt mit der
Freiheit ohne
meine Freiheit ist hier drin in meinem
Herzen
da fühle ich meine Freiheit
wenn ich auf dem Hof bin und Felder sehe
dann belastet es mich ich war schon als
Kind gerne draußen
ich liebte es lange Waldspaziergänge zu
machen dort habe ich immer eine
Verbindung zu Gott gespürt ich vermisse
das sehr
Angela Heep schreibt schon seit
Jahrzehnten Menschen im Todestrakt
oft mehreren parallel
für Sie als Pensionärin und Junggesellin
ein ideales Hobby das ihr helfe zu
verhindern dass ihr Englisch dass sie
sonst nur noch wenig brauche einrosten
ist das fahrverfahren
eigentlich schon seit jungen wo man noch
kein Telefon kann ich eigentlich auch
viel geschrieben wo ich neue Pferde bin
da kann ich bis zu 20 30
[Musik]
selber aber
ja eigentlich schon besonders vielleicht
werden
aber ich bin nicht speziell der Fotograf
einmal
und dann was haben sie für Rückmeldungen
ja
haben Sie gemerkt im Laufe der Zeit wo
sitzt mit dem schriebe das gotisches
Willi dass das aber ein anderes
vorgestellt und wenn ich ihn dann
Ganztag der Heimat haha ist das
eigentlich gerade fast parallel die
briefkundschafterverlauf
[Musik]
Freundschaft ist eigentlich nie
Freundschaft und doch habe ich mir jetzt
wieder zurückziehen und für mich Sie und
das tut mir eigentlich sehr gut dass ich
wieder für mich
habe ganze
Kathrin
im Gefängnis von der Möglichkeit mit
jemandem aus der Schweiz in Kontakt zu
kommen und ließ sich auf eine Warteliste
setzen in vielen Fällen dauert es Monate
oder Jahre bis sich jemand findet wer
also Kapazität hat darf mehreren
schreiben
serienintensiven Briefwechsel sprich
also es ist wirklich fast täglich wo man
mich schrieb und da liegt
intensiv will schriebe dann bin ich der
Hund hat
und dann wird es demjenigen gegenüber
nicht gerechtfinden
zu machen will die sind also wirklich
enorm
dankbar oder darauf angewiesen dass hier
und dann wäre es nicht fair
also im Moment eher nicht
ganz
freundschaftsherz zu vergehen ja
eigentlich schon
aus einer 2 ist in den vergangenen
Jahren zunehmend eine Dreierbeziehung
geworden
ist domini präsent im Leben der Studers
intensiv jeder Tag Kontakt mit ihrem
Freund wie findet sie das
also was ganze angefangen hat
haben wir darüber geredet und ich finde
das eine Honig sie ist für sie
Abwechslung und es ist für sie ist es
gut
und für Sie
ich muss sagen ich akzeptiere
das Delikt sei kein Thema zwischen ihr
und ihrem Brieffreund sagt Kathrin
Studer
[Musik]
sie wissen nur dass er verurteilt wurde
wegen Vergewaltigungen Mord dass sie so
jemanden in ihr Leben gelassen hat
verstehen nicht alle
[Musik]
mitochter ist
mehr als ein Jahr sehr skeptisch gesehen
sie hat das irgendwie nicht ganz
so beschäftigt wofür wo ob sie zum uns
direkt oder nicht
sie hätte wo sie schon sagen andere
Frauen die mit anderen Frauen
telefonieren stundenlang oder danke mir
ehrlich
Antwort auf das Problem wenn ich denk er
lügt wirklich von der dritte Seite
unsere Familie
würde sie dann ihn zur Familie Zähler
schon fast ja
auch für Patrick Gerber trat das Delikt
schnell in den Hintergrund aus einem
Fremden Mörder wurde ein enger Freund
ich wollte ihn nicht meinen Enkel nennen
und er mich nicht Vater oder so also
habe ich entschieden ihn Bruder zu
nennen denn ich konnte nie so offen mit
meinen Eltern reden wie ich es mit
meinem Bruder konnte
also ist er eine Art jüngerer Bruder für
mich und wir verstehen uns großartig wir
sind sehr offen keiner hat vor dem
anderen je etwas versteckt
[Musik]
am Anfang kam es zu einer beiderseitigen
Irritation aus Patrick Gerber seinem
tief religiösen Brieffreund nämlich
sagte er sei schwul ja
nimmt wie Sie sie und nicht tut
verurteilen und aber das sind die Sorge
sind im Bezug auf die Homosexualität hat
dann hätte er schon Ausdruck auch
verlegt ich habe gesagt Patrick du
kannst dich gegen die Homosexualität
entscheiden das glaubte ich wirklich er
antwortete mein Coming Out war ein
langer Prozess den ich nicht freiwillig
auf mich genommen hätte
da wurde mir klar wie falsch ich lag
ich denke schon
gegangen ist
ich glaube für mich einfach geht so aus
ist okay leider muss also ich glaube
wahrscheinlich aber Prozessor machen
Lilia Allemann ist geschieden die Kinder
sind erwachsen und aus dem Haus
darum hat die gebürtige Mexikanerin Zeit
um spanischsprachigen Gefangenen zu
schreiben
sie hatte schon diverse Brieffreunde
einer wie wir besonders in Erinnerung
bei der Besuch von die letzte Besuche er
hat viel Sport getrieben und dann ist
eine ganz starke Mann
hier die Saturn im Gefängnis weil seine
Taufe er hat sich bekehrt so Jesus er
hat Sachen gemacht dass er bis am
Schluss
zutiefst bereut hat was denn Menschen
umgebracht und
in Einfluss von Alkohol und Drogen
er hatte sich nicht in Kontrolle und er
hat Sachen gemacht das später wenn er
frei war von die Drogen und uns sich
besonnen hat hat bisher am Schluss von
seinen bereut der Schmerz der der ein
anderer Leute verursacht hat
hat er denn gesehen aber es war nicht
mehr das Leben von diese
Menschen konnte man nicht mehr
zurückbringen
der Verein life Spark ist nicht religiös
Lilia Allemann schon ihre Motivation ist
Nächstenliebe und der Glaube prägt auch
ihre Sicht auf die vielen Mörder mit
ihnen sind Kontakt gekommen ist ja aber
wir hören eine angeborene Graus gegeben
diese Art von Taten und das ist korrekt
und ist gut aber die ist nicht meine
ich bin nicht dafür gesendet worden die
Menschen zu richten
ich nehme zur Kenntnis und es braucht
mir noch mal Überwindung ich fokussiere
auf den Menschen
die Menschen für die Jesus gestorben ist
und ich versuche sie zu sehen wie Jesus
sie sieht sonst habe ich keine Chance
keine
[Musik]
das geht natürlich Frauen
Gefangenen
unbedingt aber
für mich
und auch vom
Arbeitstag
es gab nicht
in die
gefühlsdienst durcheinander wir haben
die Sache thematisiert mit Arturo ja ich
hatte er hatte mich gern und dann wir
haben die Sachen thematisiert und wir
sollten uns miteinander fixieren auf das
was wir haben bei Freundschaft ja auf
die Freundschaft und die Sache
reinlassen und wenn ich ich sehe viele
von die Gefangenen haben eine
Freundschaft und sie
kommt sehr sehr oft vor dass sie machen
als die Freundschaft eine Mutter
und ich sage auch alle meine Kollegen
ich darf deine Freundin deine Kollegin
deine Begleiterin sein
deine Schwester in Christus aber nur
dass sie wegen keine Mutter und ich will
keine Frauen keine andere
nur das
wenn der Tag der Hinrichtung gekommen
ist dürfen die Gefangenen Menschen die
Ihnen wichtig sind einladen dabei zu
sein auch ihre brieffreundinnen wenn Sie
wollen
und was für Gefühl haben Sie denn Tag
wissen sie das noch
also
wenn es denn soweit ist
den existiert man einfach
und vielleicht noch
Zeit wo wo denn das ist ja das ist
eigentlich fast schon
ich weiß nicht wie es mir in dem Moment
wird
jetzt den und den dafür umbrucht ich
hast Gefühl mir wirft das enorm
musterband
hatte Arturo Angst vor dem Tod
am Anfang schon nach seiner Bekehrung
Edison erfüllt und nicht durfte Jesus in
seiner Alltag weggegnen dass der Tod
verloren gegangen ist und denn in dieser
letzten Tagen er hatte vollkommene
Frieden man sagt dass er war total
locker
irgendwas war da ein paar Tagen vor
seiner Hinrichtung
und
war total ruhig es war ja ich habe
gesehen er hatte natürlich in der
letzten Moment
war wie die Nerven fast am Ende
hat gesittet und so kann sein dass er
Angst bekommen hatte am Schluss kann ich
nicht verurteilen aber die Stunden
voraus er hat gesagt das seien die beste
Stunden sein die beste Tagen seines
Lebens
die beste Tage in seines Lebens die Tage
vor seiner Hinrichtung
in den USA ist die Todesstrafe höchst
umstritten viele Bundesstaaten haben es
inzwischen abgeschafft oder vollziehen
sie nicht mehr
gestanden
nicht
darüber gesehen
und schaden
dass das Gift eh nicht laufen und den
kammerfrauen sondern
auch eine stehen
der Doktor
und
Wasser in das eine sehr intensive
Momente aber
dann kam den
ich bin parat es hatte ich gerade ich
bin parat
und
bekam er den der
die
Sache die Zeit ist still geblieben ich
erinnere mich jetzt als keine Zeit mehr
gäbe und
die Minuten wurde eine Ewigkeit
wie ist der
die verantwortliche dort sagte dass
ich habe gedacht ja jetzt ist der zu
Jesus gegangen
und jetzt frei jetzt von wirklich frei
er ist wirklich frei wir halten sagen
20 Minuten und noch eine
also ja und ich bin
komisch kann ich das Gefühl kann
ich denkt ja
verabschieden
ja
also mir ist es eigentlich relativ gut
gegangen
ständig über seine Hinrichtung nach
nein überhaupt nicht
man versucht das auszublenden
wenn man immer denkt bekomme ich wohl
heute mein Datum verliere ich meine
Berufung
das ist nicht gut
ich denke die meisten Menschen im
Todestag versuchen sich mit anderen
Dingen zu beschäftigen
zum Beispiel mit einer Brieffreundschaft
Patrick Gerber mit seinem Partner der
schnell verstanden hat wie wichtig diese
Brieffreundschaft ist für Patrick Gerber
aber vor allem auch für dessen Freund im
Todestag
generell
wichtiges Merkmal vom Verein life Spark
das ist aber langjährige sehr lange
Energie
bald nach diesen Aufnahmen hat Patrick
Gerber von seinem Brieffreund gehört
dass seine jahrelangen Rekurse gegen das
Todesurteil Erfolg gehabt hätten die
Todesstrafe sei in lebenslange Haft
umgewandelt worden
sind sie glücklich darüber nein
man ist nicht glücklich über
lebenslangehaft
sind sie erleichtert
nein ich bin auch nicht erleichtert als
ich es den anderen Insassen erzählt habe
sagten alle gratulation zur lebenslangen
Haft was
wie kann man jemanden zur lebenslangen
Haft gratulieren
wenn ich eine Erleichterung verspüre
dann nicht weil ich nicht hingerichtet
werde
sondern weil ich nun ein bisschen mehr
Freiheiten bekomme innerhalb des
Gefängnisses und darum neue Aufgaben
übernehmen kann
was auch immer das sein wird
dass ich weiterleben darf muss einen
Sinn haben und diesen Sinn will ich
finden
ich bin sicher gott hat einen Plan für
mich
[Musik]
vielleicht hat ja tatsächlich jemand
Pläne mit uns und für uns
[Musik]
mit denen in Freiheit
und mit den anderen
[Musik]
vielleicht geben sie einander ja ein
wenig Sinn
die freien den Gefangenen und umgekehrt
alle viele Freunde haben mich das
gezeigt dass sie dankbar sind für diese
Vertrauen und dass sie Menschen sind
dass sie als Menschen bald genommen
werden das ist ist was sie sehr gern
haben
darum muss man sie erinnern dass sie
Menschen sind
dass sie sich als solche verhalten
[Musik]